c'est un des films les plus attendus de
l'automne lucky luke sort demain sur les
écrans avec dans le rôle-titre notre
invité jean dujardin devenu en quelques
années l'un des acteurs français les
plus populaires
adapter une bande dessinée aussi connu
c'est un pari difficile mais le film est
parvenu à éviter les pièges
eric cornet et alexandre dupont est
celui que je vous demande de rétablir
l'ordre
adapter lucky luke au cinéma de
réalisateurs dont rnd s'il s'y sont
cassé les dents web
alors pour éviter les écueils au risque
de rater les puristes le réalisateur a
inventé aux pauvres cow boy solitaire un
passé une blessure d'enfance qui sert de
point de départ à l'histoire on allait
créer une histoire qui est étirée
d'aucun album on a pu prendre de ceux de
ce parti pris là beaucoup beaucoup
d'éléments de plein d'albums différents
ainsi si les dalton et rantanplan sont
absents du casting on retrouve la
plupart des légendes de l'ouest qui
jalonnent les aventures de luxe d'avoir
une dalle de calamity jane à billy the
kid en passant par jesse james
bien plus que de simples méchant
ce pacte à bazire abed 6 caractères
c'était un super acteur jesse c'est quoi
tes et sarah bernhardt est des points
même si c'est des grands bandits et
qu'ils sont a priori les ennemis de
lucky luke
ils viennent tous touchants même billy
the kid qui est joué par un michaël youn
au début on se dit mais attend ce sale
gosse vraiment il est possible qu'il y
ait volume et deux plaqués au lit alors
qu'en fait au bout d'un moment on se dit
il est charmant il est touchant il un
prêt avec ses parents à régler enfin à
côté mais un peu assez profond
finalement chaque jour les personnages
touchant aussi devoir lucky luke fondre
devant une belle star de salon y est la
chef de transformer le héros presque
asexué pas très glamour de la bd en vrai
héros de cinéma son histoire d'amour
elle et moi j'adore parce qu'elle veut
je la trouve super drôle j'avoue que
c'est à 1 c'est un homme qui se retrouve
avec un pote avec des seins sait pas
trop pour que ton régionalise à la fois
comédie western et aventure celui qui
lutte version 2009 se veut fidèle à
l'esprit de la bd
seul le public en jugera